[Music]
i think than it is particularly
different from any other district in the
whole of the country we have an area
that has
communities from all different
backgrounds
that represent all different societies
and
we have to be able to show that on on
the council the residence is diverse so
it's just you know councillors should be
a reflection
of the chamber should be a reflection of
the um district we do need younger
people that there
and i knocked on many doors and i told
them that because i can't do this
forever i feel sometimes i've been out
there
40 years plus not just in politics but
campaigning younger councillors have
their finger on the pulse of a different
you know set of of people they will have
contacts you know just their own
contacts amongst a wider range of people
i think more and more young people
especially
their involvement in politics is often
pushed to one side because they are
young and immature and and actually it's
the opposite of that they should be
involved in in what decisions going on
because they are the ones that are going
to be affected the most different people
will bring different things to it so for
example some of the councillors we've
got that have been councillors for years
before their experience is really
important but what's been nice that
we've seen happening more recently is
many more women coming into local
politics many more younger councillors
that we've got now what we still need to
do is appeal to a more diverse spread of
the population
[Music]